consider the following table of values
for a linear function f of x is equal to
mx plus b and an exponential function g
of x is equal to a times r to the x
write the equation for each function and
so they give us for each x value what f
of x is and what g of x is and we need
to figure out the equation for each
function and type them in over here so i
copy and pasted this problem on my
little scratch pad so let's first think
about the linear function and to figure
out a the to figure out the equation of
a line or a linear function right over
here you really just need two points and
i always like to use the situation when
x equals zero because that
makes it very clear
what the y intercept is going to be so
for example we can say
that f of 0
f of 0 is going to be equal to
m
times 0
plus b
or this is just going to be equal to b
and they tell us that f of 0 is equal to
5.
b is equal to 5. so we immediately know
that this
b right over here is equal to 5. now we
just have to figure out the m we have to
figure out the slope of this line
so just as a little bit of refresher on
slope
the slope of this line is going to be
our change in y or a change in our
function i guess we could say if we say
that this is y is equal to f of x over
our change in x and actually let me
write it that way we could write this as
our change in our function
over our change in x if you want to look
at it that way
so let's look at this first change in x
when x goes from zero to one so we
finish at one we started at zero and f
of x finishes at seven and started at
five so when x is one f of x is seven
when x is zero f of x is 5 and we get
a change in our function of 2 when x
changes by 1. so our m is equal to 2 and
you see that when x increases by 1 our
function increases by 2.
so now we know the equation for f of x
f of x
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to 2
times
2 x
plus b or 5. so we figured out what f of
x is now we need to figure out what g of
x is so g of x is an exponential
function and there's really two things
that we need to figure out we need to
figure out what a is and we need to
figure out what r is and let me just
rewrite that so
we know that g of x maybe i'll do it
down here
g of x
is equal to a times r to the x power
and if we know what g of 0 is that's a
pretty useful thing because r to the
zeroth power regardless of what r is
where i guess we could assume that r is
not equal to zero that leads to people
can debate what zero to the zero power
is but if r is any non-zero number we
know that you raise that to the zero
power you get one and so that
essentially gives us a so let's just
write that down
g of zero
g of zero is a times r to the zero power
which is just going to be equal to a
times 1 or a
and they tell us what g of 0 is g of 0
is equal to 3 so we know that a is equal
to 3. so so far we know that our g of x
can be written as 3
times r to the x power
so now we can just use any one of the
other values they gave us to solve for r
for example they tell us that g of 1 is
equal to
2. so let's write that down g
of 1
which would be 3
times
r to the first power or just 3 let me
just write it could be 3 times r to the
first power or we could just write that
as 3 times r
they tell us that g of 1 is equal to 2
is equal to 2. so we get 3 times r is
equal to 2 or we get that r is equal to
2 3. divide both sides of this equation
by
three so r is two-thirds and we're done
g of x
g of x
is equal to three
times two-thirds
three times two-thirds actually just
write this way
three times two-thirds to the x power
three times two-thirds to the x-power or
you could write it that way if you want
any which way so three times two-thirds
to the x-power and f of x is 2x 5. so
let's actually just type that in
so f of x is 2x plus 5
f of x is 2 x plus 5 and we can verify
that that's the expression that we want
and g of x is three
times
two over three
two over three
to the
to the
x power let me just verify that that's
what i did there i have a short memory
all right yeah that looks right
all right let's check our answer and we
got it right